google the words famous dog and the
first image you'll see
is a bright-eyed pug with his tongue
sticking out i'm leslie
and i'm rob and this is doug the pug we
are interrupting his
mid-afternoon nap so if you hear his
little snores
that's what the noise is this all
started in the year 2014.
i always wanted a pug named doug ever
since i was a little girl it just felt
like
the best name you could ever name a pug
in my opinion and when i moved to
nashville tennessee to go to college
i felt like it was finally time for me
to get my dream dog
from the moment that i brought him home
he sat in front of the tv and watched
the kardashians on repeat and
i was like is my brand new puppy
watching the kardashians like super
intently
from that moment on i knew that he was
really
interested in consuming and absorbing
pop culture
doug loved being dressed up he'd wag his
tail when i was about to put on
a shirt and he would lift his paw trying
to get his paw
into the shirt whenever there was a
camera in front of doug
it was like he had to be on and he would
sit there and pose
he's just a little diva craving
attention all the time
and if you don't give him attention he
demands it so
i started getting pretty creative with
him around nashville and taking him
to different parks or you know putting
him on a skateboard and dressing him
like a skater pug
and it became this thing that i really
looked forward to
after work i started posting doug on my
personal instagram account
and immediately i realized that people
did not really care about seeing me they
wanted to only see dougie
and it was actually rob here who i had
just started dating at the time
he was the person who was like you
should just make doug his own
instagram account so we started doug's
instagram people started liking it
following the account and all these like
plugs of instagram
would repost doug's photos and it just
kind of took off
really really quickly when doug hit a
hundred thousand on instagram we were so
ecstatic and
threw a hundred thousand party and
invited all of our friends
the next day i was trying to think of a
funny post for doug's account
and i thought oh my gosh i have these
pug balloons i might as well do
something with these
i tied the balloon around doug's little
waist and
just filmed him running around the park
just being
his crazy self i edited it up i sent it
over to her
posted it and i woke up the next morning
and the video had
20 million views on facebook this is
where things started to get crazy
all of a sudden we started getting hit
up by good morning america
buzzfeed we ended up taking this little
guy to new york city
we had meetings all day doug loved going
to all of the press offices
and would just cause mayhem we just let
him off the leash and he'd
run around and go to people's cubicles
and he'd jump on the table
and it would just be this like moment of
pandemonium but
everyone was so happy doug got a book
deal shortly after that new york city
trip
and that book ended up being on the new
york times bestseller list
celebrities started following doug and
started inviting him to their concerts
doug got to meet justin bieber billy
eilish baby perry you know you see them
on camera and the moment that they meet
doug they get to just be
a normal person and it's obvious that
they miss their dogs and
it doug brings a really happy moment for
celebrities
david dobrik said that doug the pug is
his internet crush
we just so happen to be in chicago and i
get a dm from david like oh my god
come to my show tonight so he took him
out on stage and like danced with him
and the crowd went crazy doug had a role
in the katy perry music video for swish
swish
we literally got an email one night and
they were like
can you be in la in two days that was a
crazy experience
doug got to meet kobe the cat in san
francisco and they had a great time
shakira flew us all to barcelona just to
meet doug we were hanging out in her
backyard and all of a sudden doug
saw that one of the doors was open and
he decided to sprint
into that door and run into her house
running from room to room
he wouldn't let us catch him he was so
excited and luckily shakira was
very kind and thought it was hilarious
one of the fun business sides of doug
the pug
is that we've gotten really into the
licensing world and
now doug has dozens upon dozens of
stuffed animals that
are modeled exactly after him and what
he wears he's
the happiest guy ever living the life
he's treated like gold
at the end of the day our mission is to
bring joy and spread love and spread
happiness through doug
we've been working very hard on the doug
the pug foundation
we'll be helping kids with childhood
cancer and other life-threatening
illnesses
and use the donations to help kids and
their families who need it the most
we feel so grateful and so fortunate
that we are able to make a living
we like to think of doug as a bright
spot on the internet that can sometimes
be a dark place
and with the world right now and how
stressful everything
is i think we can all look to doug and
his cute little face to
bring some joy and doug is happy to
oblige oh yeah
[Music]
you